pedro and laura have been traveling
since may when they sold their business
and left their native cuba the pandemic
combined with u.s sanctions has caused
unprecedented food shortages and
hardship at home
last summer the communist regime in
havana faced its biggest protests in
decades leading to a harsh crackdown
the government talks about the external
embargo a great deal but there's an even
worse internal one the government seizes
agricultural production and distributes
food as it deems fit you cannot vote for
the president there are only certain
types of businesses you can be licensed
to do there's no democracy there are
people who disappear who've been killed
to get to greece laura and pedro flew to
moscow where cubans can travel without a
visa
from there they flew to belgrade also
visa-free then walked most of the way
through serbia and north macedonia into
greece
their goal was to reach spain or italy
they ended up on the greek island of
zakinthus where they planned to catch a
flight to milan in northern italy
but about 130 other cubans had the same
idea on the same day
this is what happened when police tried
to arrest them
it seems that this flight was oversold
and when the police saw one cuban
passport after another they put us all
into separate rooms they kept us there
for eight hours and told us they were
going to take us to a hotel instead they
took people to the police station their
woman children there pedro and laura
have now joined the thousands of
refugees who live legally or illegally
in athens
unlike african and asian nationals
who've sought asylum here for years
cubans in the balkans are a completely
new phenomenon greece is an attractive
way station for asylum seekers who want
to travel deeper into europe it has a
thousand kilometers of mountainous land
border which are difficult to police
and it's a member of the schengen area
which means that once here it's
relatively easy for someone to travel to
25 other european countries without
border controls
cuban's first port of call would
normally be the united states charles
cook is an immigration lawyer in the u.s
and explains what's happening the system
was broken by the trump administration
uh and so far the byte administration is
10 months in office has not really made
a lot of effort to fix that
because of coven so all these all these
factors are coming into play here that
are driving people to other places
and greece is the other place right now
hundreds of cubans are now in greece and
they're waiting to find out whether
authorities will take up their asylum
applications or encourage them to keep
walking
john saropolos al jazeera athens